so I know you're a huge fan of conye
West oh yeah how has that been yes are
you guys still friends you've heard
about this whole anti-Semitism thing he
been talking about yeah apparently he
hates Jews apparently that's what he
saying not Kanye look all I can tell you
is my experience with Kanye West which
was in
2017 I ended up getting involved in in
his bask he did a basketball run I
literally met him on the basketball
court first time meeting Kanye by the
way full court three on three me
guarding Kanye why is it full court
three on three just to get that run in
and we only had six people there but
who's the whose idea was that why not
keep it on the half I think people just
wanted to exercise more wow yeah and so
that's my first time meeting him how was
he how could how he play very
interesting game like good shooter but
like I feel like very awkward form he
just is so weirdly good at finishing
around the hoop in a way that you're
like that's never going to work and he
like does these weird finger rules that
go in Fairly Kanye can hoop yeah wow he
can hoop a little bit
um anyways forgiven my experience with
him I would like play basketball with
him for like a year like twice a week
and like it involved into a little like
he would invite me to come to his Works
place and like show me the new music
he's working on and the clothing and
like I like had a real and he was
nothing but nice to me the entire time
like truly like was one of the nicest
like and this is my hero like no one I
told him to his face I don't know if I
would have the self-belief that I have
if I wasn't like my former of years
weren't like listening to this other
person having this like insane
self-belief in himself and like that
being the soundtrack to my life and I
believe that like you know what I mean
like and I owe a lot to his art for like
making me my attitude is probably formed
by like early Kanye and we had a great
relationship he's uh like he changed his
number at some point like to the point
where like you know he does that a lot I
think where he changes his number he
proba have to at that level changes his
team um and I just lost touch with him
for you know just the way and I haven't
seen him in like four years and I
obviously see all the things that uh and
I was like surprised cuz like I don't
think in his heart Kanye uh dislikes
Jewish people you know I don't I know he
knows I'm Jewish I know he likes me you
know what I mean so in my heart I feel
like he probably said something and uh
it was the wrong thing I'm sure I'm not
denying that he'll say the wrong thing
often you know what I mean like I think
he might have said the wrong thing
people got outraged I think the thing
that he can't stand the most is when
people tell him what he can or cannot
say so then he leans in into it and
that's the real now I don't think you
should be leading into it I'm not saying
what he did is the right like I think
that there should be a sensitivity to
like Jewish people you you don't think
that at his core there's anti-Semitism
you think at his core is rebellion and
right now this is the thing that's kind
of what now this is really me theorizing
I'm not that close to the situation I
played basketball with him like for a
year but let me tell you he was the
sweetest man like and I watched him
interact with a variety of different
people being really nice um and so
that's
I'm not I can see that with him like
just being such a I don't want to say
contrarian actually just caring about
Freedom so much that that's the thing I
really think that like the Trump hat
like do I think he like loves Trump's
policies no I think he wore the Hat one
time people were like you can't wear
that and then he wore it for a year I
think and I think he does feel like
we're controlled a lot by like media and
like opinion and I I kind of see a lot
of uh interesting thought process in
terms of like him being at the Forefront
of like he's really is always ahead of
the curve in a lot of things that being
said you know my mother is outraged by
his comments and rightfully so but I
think at his core I really believe he's
a good guy yeah yeah that's tough yeah
you're friends with both of them who's
the better artist Drake or Kanye better
Artist Artist man I can't even they're
both they they here's what I'll say I
was in the studio one time with Kanye
and it was just like me and Kanye and
and and one other man and it was like
already I'm like this is the best day of
my life like I'm like showing the Freaky
Friday music video before it's even out
I have my best bullet of content that
I've ever had before it comes out to
like show did he watch yeah and he was
like that's amazing and then Drake
walked in theu and I had no idea Drake
was even coming and I'm like oh so they
were in the studio together this was a
while ago but yes they you know they
they they've worked together plenty of
times back in like 2017 they have like a
real friend of me thing and I'm in there
with both of them and I took the
opportunity to be like fellas let me
just tell both of you while you're here
that you guys are so by far my favorite
two artists of all time that whoever is
third what a sizable Gap there is
between you two and the third play and
that's how I feel about them like I
think Kanye was coming when I was a kid
and I love Kanye's music and like you
know not only just the messaging behind
like the ambition but also the
musicality and like doing like that [__]
sounds better than ever and it's like so
original and is ins and Drake came along
right when I became like a rapper and
like man nothing has inspired me more as
an actual rapper and and musical artist
than Drake like that guy every time I
feel like I'm like hitting a LOL as a
rapper and I'm like I'm like I don't
know how much I want to go to the studio
today because like I kind of am a little
bit like in a writer blocky situation
where I'm not loving then Drake drops
like the most inspiring [__] I've ever
heard and makes like totally and I just
and both of them have been so nice to me
so I can't really delineate between
Drake and Connie they're just my
favorite artist ever I also want to know
whenever you get into a situation like
you're at like a party and there's
someone that you really admire that's
there what is your protocol for how to
interact with them cuz you're just a
regular dude from Philly all of a sudden
now you're at these Hollywood parties
what do you do
uh I won't i i w you know I I'll try to
have an organic you know I won't like be
like angling the whole time like okay
there's Brad Pit over there I'm going to
go inch my way closer to him hope he
sees my I don't I'm not really strategic
like that but if I end up being in the
same conversation look they either have
seen my work and honestly if they have
they probably really respect me and like
me or they've never seen my work and I'm
just a guy and I think everything I I've
done in my career has spawned off the
premise
of the way I behave in real life tends
to be a way that people enjoy like I
really just started as like an enjoyable
funny conversationally pleasing man and
that's how I carry myself so I just act
the way I act with whoever I'm meeting
not with like designs of like winning
them over and getting them in my show
but like I just want I you know the same
way I'd want to be liked by anybody I
try to be liked by whoever I'm talking
to and try to be a Charming version of
myself and often times it leads to
positive creative Synergy if later I'm
like I have a great idea for this person
oh I met them at that one party like
when I called them like I remember that
guy he's cool he's nice he's not a weird
guy a lot of artists are really
introverted and like don't want to be
approached and don't want to be talked
to I'm just not that way like anytime a
fan comes up to me and talks to me like
um I find it minimally even if it's the
most brutally awkward interaction ever
I'm like like what a unique human
interaction that was that I'll forever
remember the specificity of and be able
to like mind comedy from or they'll be
like really normal and shower me with
praise like either way I don't lose you
know so I just think I approach
everything the same way I'm talking to
anybody and that I think is why a lot of
these icons resonate with me because
they can tell that I'm just being myself
but you're comfortable complimenting
them and telling them how much you
admire them oh yeah like I know how much
it means to me when Drake and Kanye tell
me they [__] with me so I know how much
maybe it'll mean to someone else if I
tell I mean who knows it doesn't mean
anything BR to Brad Pit but like I I
sure in my email to Brad Pit I certainly
said you have like totally defined like
Cinema for me for my whole you know what
I mean like and it's true and I the guys
like Brad Pit worked their ass off and
so that means a lot to them yeah they
want to influence a generation and a
culture and I think they like hearing
that like these new wave of people
wouldn't be inspired for sure yeah yeah
yeah I think yeah I think that makes a
lot of sense I think there's sometimes
people maybe in their discomfort with
you know withhold their true feelings or
admiration for the person that they're
talking posture I like really keep it
real at all times and I think that is
genuinely accepted like people like that
especially if it's coming from a real
place not like you're trying to Shmo
them but when you really I don't know
I've always felt that like when I really
admire someone for a specific thing not
that they're just the famous person
around I really [__] admire them the
conversation is so easy yeah cuz you
have a million things that want to say
that are nuanced and specific and they
can see that you actually care about the
art or the thing that they're doing and
is the easiest flow in the world it's
always uncomfortable like when I just
don't admire them and I don't care and
in those situations I'm not going to
bother you I don't care if famous you
are yeah but yeah I think that is good
point lead with what you [__] care
about I really think the core of my
entire being and the success I've had
really comes from being yourself like I
think there that's a reason that I'm
able to be a white rapper making jokes
in a predominantly black landsape cuz
I'm just not coming in and like trying
to like act like Mr cool guy I'm just
like being myself yeah and remember if
you sign up use that promo code Shultz
they will match your initial deposit up
to $100 that means you put in a 100 you
get 100 for free go to prix.com